bladesmiths welcome to the ice block
shop you ready to go jay i was born
ready
[Music]
let's do it
the scottish back sword
known for assaulting axis positions with
his scottish backsword drawn mad jack
churchill earned his name and the
respect of his troops for his famed
exploits during world war ii the back
sword first came a fashion during the
16th century and is recognized for its
basket hill that covers the user's hand
offering complete protection
featuring a straight and lethal single
edge the weapon was a brutal slicer and
thruster on the battlefield especially
when wielded by mad jack
a true wartime hero mad jack eventually
served as a commando leader helping the
allied forces save europe from
destruction
all right bladesmiths captain matt jack
churchill may have been mad enough to
take a backsword into modern combat but
what i want to know is
are your swords mad enough if called
upon to kill
to that end i will deliver some killing
blows to this ballistics dummy
de la hero first you ready for this i
came here to watch you kill and chew
bubble gum and i'm out of bubble gum all
right
let's do this
[Music]
all right billy
first stop i really like the way the
damascus batter shows in your sword
now your handle
it's comfortable there are no hot spots
every cut you do with this blade is
sharp enough to cut deeply
overall
your weapon will kill
thank you very much all right robert
your turn sir are you ready i'm ready
let's do this
[Music]
i will not be denied
all right roberts talk about your back
sword here
the tip
very pointy
thrust in easily cuts on the way out
your handle here it's loose it's really
wiggling in my hand
but overall sir your back sword
will kill
thank you
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
today i'm going to take your swords and
i'm going to clear a path through this
big block of ice i don't really care
what your swords do to the ice i want to
see what the ice does to your swords
billy
you look ready to be first jay i was
born ready
[Music]
billy nice job thank you i'm sure you
could see when i was striking that the
blade flexed all over the place and came
right back to where it was in the
beginning everything's tight
nice job thank you very much
robert how you feeling i'm ready good
i'm ready too
oh no
i really don't know what to think right
now it's right here is where it hurts
feels like something pulled watching jay
scream out in pain like that i feel that
pain as well it's kind of catching me a
little bit back here
i hate that something that i did caused
pain to another person plus it's loose
i see jay stepping off the testing floor
i'm pretty sure this is this is the this
is it for me
bladesmiths in any one of our finale
competitions the way that you design
those blades to perform in our
challenges is always taken into
consideration
and robert unfortunately your weapon has
hurt our user so severely that we had to
send them to the emergency room
your weapon has been given a vote of no
confidence and cannot move forward in
testing
and for that reason i have to ask you to
please leave the forge
first and foremost i hope that jay
doesn't suffer any long-term effects of
this injury i took my time making sure
that everything was safe on this blade
so to find out that i missed something
it's kind of devastating you know
billy your blade is sharp deadly and
strong and you are the forge of fire
champion and that is a title that comes
with a check for 10 000 good job brother
whoa
i'm the forged in fire champion this is
awesome
this is definitely not the way that i
hope to win
but i was given the privilege of doing
this for a day when i can also honor
those who have given me the freedom to
do this
this has been an amazing experience and
i'm very blessed and honored to have
been a part of
the northern long sacs
the northern long sax is a single edge
blade widely used by vikings and
northern european tribes during the
middle ages
its razor sharp edge and pointed tip
were useful in slashing as well as for
thrusting
allowing the user to deliver heavy blows
and stabs to finish off an opponent in
close quarter combat
although used as a deadly weapon the
vikings would also use the sax to hack
tree branches and skin animals
today the versatile blade can be seen in
netflix historical drama series the last
kingdom all right bladesmiths welcome to
the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i will take your
weapon deliver some lethal blows on this
big carcass
clay you ready to play yes sir all right
let's do this
oh
all right clay let's talk about your
northern long sacks here
do you have a forward heavy blade with
that forward weight it really allows for
deeper chops
the edges are sharp they cut deep
and overall sir your weapon
you'll kill that's all i wanted to hear
all right dapper devon
you're up next are you ready sir i'm
pumped let's do this
[Music]
nice
thanks man
all right devin let's talk about your
weapon here
the blade you have here is nicely
balanced that when i cut the weapon does
not do the work for me i do the work
with every slash as you can see i cut it
down twice all the way through
overall sir your northern log sacks
thank you sir
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
fittingly for this arctic challenge
we're going to do the ice block chop
[Music]
it really tests the edge holding and
overall construction your knives
it's a lot of fun too
clay your purse you ready to go
give her hell
[Music]
all right clay you got a little bit of
an issue here
your grain's not that bad
i mean it could be finer but it's not
that bad
but
every time i hit that blade just
vibrated like crazy and it just traveled
down so it started to bend and then all
that vibration and everything it just
finally came loose i hate to see a nice
damascus pattern like this have
something happen to it like that but
hey it's a good fight man
we hate to see you clay unfortunately
your blade did succumb to this test but
you're not out of fight yet
devin
you have to survive six blows in the
same test to claim the title and the
check for ten thousand dollars you ready
let's do it
well devin congratulations man thank you
clay
difficult test i want to say thank you
so much for your hard work but
unfortunately due to the catastrophic
failure we couldn't continue the testing
so unfortunately man
time here the forge has ended i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step out thank
you i didn't expect that my blade was
gonna break but ice is just a super hard
test for any blade no matter what well
devin congratulations man you are
today's arctic forge champion you
absolutely deserve it that is a brutal
test and you crushed it thank you
i can't believe this just happened
i am the forge of fire champion and i'm
just thanking all the support i've had
from my wife
my first plan is to take my wife to
miami and we're going to get out of this
cold weather and go sit on the beach for
at least four days and just relax in the
sunlight i'm very excited
the boateng sabre
the boateng sabre holds the world record
as the most expensive sword ever sold at
7.7 million dollars
commissioned by the chinese emperor kui
long in the 18th century this elaborate
weapon is inlaid with gold copper and
jewels
in addition to its beauty the slightly
curved blade featured a sharp lethal
edge
ideal for slashing into an opponent
combining artisanal craftsmanship and
deadly practicality this weapon is
worthy of an all-powerful ruler
basements welcome to the kill test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
we'll take your weapons deliver some
lethal blows on this or carcass it's
time to find out if your blades will
stand up to the most expensive blade
ever sold in auction or if they're going
on a fortifier reduce sale
cleveland you're up first you ready for
this yes i am all right
[Music]
all right glenn let's talk about your
weapon here
your edge is sharp that's a thick hide
right there and it chops deep into it
overall sir your bow tang
will kill
all right back to our dance are you
ready let's bring home the bacon
sure dude
all right matt like the bounce you have
your weapon here your handle is a little
bit blocky so when you have a blocky
handle right there when you're swinging
for the rafters right there with full
power it tends to move around i can't
get full grip on this
your edge is sharp though
some of the chops there it goes deep
it will kill thank you
welcome to one of my favorite tests the
ice block chop
super-sized
now i'm going to take your swords and
beat them repeatedly and mercilessly
into this large block of ice
a good strong sword should be able to
hold up to the stress
one that's not so good might chip bend
or even break apart
gladen how you feeling buddy a little
nauseous okay we'll get over quick for
you fingers crossed
oh
all right clayton nice job a little bit
forward heavy
but good strong blade
your edge is perfect no damage at all
good job
how you feeling matt
after watching that i don't know
well we're gonna find out
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
all right matt you survived everything's
still tight nothing came loose
but
your edge is
not what it was it hasn't exactly rolled
over or chipped just
doesn't have that razor edge it did have
when i started but hey then you survived
good job thank you
doug
all right bladesmith welcome to the
sharpness test that's tommy matt's slice
now we'll take your weapon and try to
cut through these tatami mats a sharp
blade should cut all the way through
beam you up first you ready yes sir
let's do it
[Music]
all right
let's talk about your edge here it's
sharp it cut through the first three
tatami's easily even on the one that's
doubled up overall sir your weapon
it will cut
thanks sir all right matt your turns are
you ready let's do it let's do it
all right matt
as you can see it did cut a little bit
but during the strength test it did get
some dulling it's still sharp but it's
not as sharp
but this is the reason why we have the
sharpness so we know how well your edge
is able to hold on to its sharpness but
you can see in the first cuts
it will cut thank you all right
gentlemen the judges have made their
final decision our new force and fire
champion is
gladen congratulations you're the forest
fire champion matt you did fantastic
work but at this time i have to ask you
to exit the forge
good job thanks very much good job forza
and fire is a really tough challenge
it really pushes you to really expand on
your skills
gladen you are the fours and fire
champion that is the title that does not
come with a check for 7.7 million but it
does come with one for 10 000. good job
brother
thank you
come over here and shake our hands thank
you man good job brother you did a great
job the whole fortune fire experience
has been fantastic for me all the
learning that i've been able to do nice
job just a little bit lighter next time
i know being the fortune fire champion
gives me the confirmation that you know
i can make
good swords and blades it really helps
me know i'm going in the right direction
so it should be 7.7 million but you know
i'll take ten thousand whoa
the arming sword
[Music]
the arming sword was the sort of choice
for medieval european knights during an
era of advanced armor with swords needed
to penetrate both armor and flesh the
blades point has a distinctive taper
allowing pinpoint thrusts into
vulnerable areas on an enemy a central
fuller in the blade reduced its weight
making it a well-balanced and effective
one-handed weapon
wielded with a shield in the opposite
hand knights were protected as they
delivered deadly blows powerful enough
to cleave a skull into in 1429 french
troops made a heroic counter-attack at
the siege of orleon led by joan of arc
wielding the arming sword
bladesmiths the arming sword it's a cut
and thrust weapon
to test the lethality of your arming
sword i will deliver slashes and thrust
on these poor carcasses
john you're up first you ready for this
yes sir let's do this
that hide is super thick to get through
that you really need a very fine edge
and not a lot of weight behind it and i
didn't build that
all right john let's talk about your
arming sword here it's heavy
it did cut on some parts of the carcass
other parts it just bounced off
thrusting wise though it did what it was
designed for
this will kill thank you sir
all right drew you're up you ready yes
sir
oh nice
[Music]
all right drew
this is a very sharp
blade a great thrusting blade and i like
how you put a counter balance right here
because all the weight is nicely
distributed so where i can thrust and
slash
your blade sir
you will kill
thank you good job thank you
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
one of my favorites the ice block chop
and we supersized it
what i'm going to do is take each of
your swords i'm going to beat them
repeatedly and viciously into this big
chunk ice it's going to test the overall
construction of your sword as well as
its edge holding ability now what your
swords do to the ice is secondary
compared to what the ice does to your
swords
and john
you're up first how you feeling buddy
nervous
well we're gonna do it anyway so yeah
[Music]
[Music]
well this is very heavy very hard to
control
also
aside from having gaps in your shoulders
here you've got a pretty good bend in
the blade and that was there before i
started
not a lot of edge left but you survived
drew how you feeling
i'm ready
[Music]
drew this is a beautiful sword thank you
blade is still
razor sharp which is very impressive
with an ice block chop
that being said the ice block chop is
meant to be brutal it's meant to test
the overall structural integrity of your
sword from tip to pommel
the problem is i'm holding your pommel
in his hand instead of this hand
so that's an issue yeah
drew
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
i'm sad that my blade failed i had a ton
of fun i would do it again in a second
i'm super excited to get back to the
west coast and just get back to work
chipping away at my custom orders
john congratulations you're the next
forager fire champion good job
thanks
you'll be receiving a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel i
didn't want to win like that but
i feel pretty good
i made butter knives in the first round
i come back with a beast of an arm and
sword and now i'm forced to fire
champion good job brother when i get
home the first thing i'm doing is buying
a press and get right back out to the
shop and forward some more it is only
driving me to do it more
the chinese war sword
the chinese war sword was a traditional
weapon of china's peasant army beginning
with the qing dynasty and continuing
through the 20th century similar to the
falshin the war sword is a massive
two-handed cleaving sword that generates
a tremendous amount of swinging power
while slashing and chopping through
opponents
with a frightening reputation as an
instrument of decapitation this blade
vanquished enemies during the boxer
rebellion and later during clashes with
japanese forces in the second
sino-japanese war
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
chinese warsaw and deliver one strike on
this
ram carcass let's see how deadly they
are
[Music]
all right bobby
one and done
as much as this is very intimidating in
its look
it is crafted nicely it's got a
beautiful look to its finish
the balance is just right for a
two-handed sword a little forward heavy
but it tells you that's where the power
is your edge is sharp even cutting
through the spine and bones no issues no
glinting no rolls overall sir your
chinese war sword
will kill thank you sir
all right well your turn ready yes sir
i'm ready let's do this
good job buddy thank you
all right well let's talk about your
chinese war sword here first up it's a
very bulky handle it's rounded
so as you get a good grip on it you can
feel it start to spread my hands around
but the wrapping that you put around it
does allow me to get a good grip on it
so good on that and one shot one kill
over alter your weapon it will kill
thank you sir
ooh i just felt a frightening chill
must be the strengthest
jay
you boys remember me yes sir yes sir
welcome to the ice block chop
this is going to test not only your edge
and your heat treat but the overall
construction of your swords
now what your blades do to the ice i'm
not too concerned about i want to see
what the ice is going to do to your
blades
bobby up first how you feeling
ready to go me too let's do it
oh
great job bobby
still razor sharp no rolls no glints
nothing
everything's still tight
i mean one of the swings i was able to
split that block
so it's got good feel uh just nice job
overall thank you
okay well
how you feeling
i'm nervous but i'm excited okay well
i'm just excited so
uh
[Music]
well we got a problem well big problem
sir right where you did your very rough
hollow grind there's a couple dark spots
right in here
and with that thin spot right there it
was enough to allow that blade to just
snap right in half on the first swing
so did not survive but
good effort
thank you sir
well well sometimes this competition is
full of tough breaks and you've had one
on the first strike against this ice
block in our strength test
unfortunately we cannot continue testing
your blade against your opponents please
leave the force to your right this
competition has given me the inspiration
to move forward and challenge myself in
new ways
bobby you are the forge and fire
champion and that's the title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
good job brother
come on forward my friend
great job great work
i feel on top of the world right now
that's a great piece man that was fun to
swing this is not just a win for me this
is a win for my family my friends the
other smiths that i teach in the forge
this goes a long ways for our whole
community
you